bonjour et bienvenue sur ma fac à terré
dans une nouvelle émission de vivre
ensemble avec jade et métis qui vont
nous parler du conseil départemental des
jeunes et geci robert le responsable
bienvenue à toutes les trois merci alors
madame robert le conseil départemental
des jeunes en quoi ça consiste
le conseil départemental des jeunes
c'est une instance qui existe depuis
1989 et en fait elle permet aux jeunes
de 4e et de 3e de pouvoir s'exprimer de
participer à la vie de leur collège est
en fait de pouvoir mener des actions
c'est aussi une instance qui permet aux
jeunes de pouvoir s'exprimer d'apprendre
à être plus à l'aise en pépites alors
qui sont les jeunes qui composent le
conseil départemental des jeunes pas ce
sont des jeunes de 4e et de 3e des
jeunes de 4e qui a un mandat de deux ans
et ceux de 3e qu'un mandat d'un an
alors on parle de collégiens comment ça
fonctionne concrètement ils ont des
séances des réunions de travail en
commission
donc il ya quatre commissions le nord le
sud l'est et l'ouest
donc ça dépend en fonction des collèges
parce qu'on a quand même 80 de collège
et à partir de là donc ils se réunissent
par secteur pour travailler pour décider
des actions à mener
très bien j'adore tu es président du
conseil départemental des jeunes c'est
un titre impressionnant pour une
collégienne
c'est vrai que ce titre peut paraître
impressionnant comme cela surtout que
c'est dans la seule instance où la
présidente est une collégienne
mais je pense que au delà du titre ce
sont plus les fonctions et les
responsabilités qu'il ya derrière qui
peuvent être assez impressionnant parce
que c'est vrai que pour une collégienne
de 13 ans comme je suis c'est assez
lourd mais oui quelques étapes poussé à
briguer ce mandat
alors comme me disait j'essaie tout à
l'heure j'étais en quatrième donc
j'étais suppléante est mort j'ai
découvert en quelque sorte le conseil
départemental des jeunes comme cela et
ça m'a vraiment intéressé l'âme
hier comment on pouvait vraiment
s'exprimer et créer des projets être un
porte parole est donc en troisième j'ai
décidé de me présenter présidente pour
représenter tous ces collégiens et faire
le lien entre entre eux et le conseil
départemental
comment est-ce que tu consultes à vis de
colas duel avec cette activité de
conseillère départementale j'avoue que
ce n'est pas forcément facile de
concilier les deux mais je fais tout mon
possible et quand je me suis présenté
présidente je connaissais toutes les
responsabilités derrière et j'avais déjà
conscience de tout ce qui m'attendais
donc je savais que j'aurai beaucoup de
choses à faire et que je serai beaucoup
demander et comme j'étais préparé je
pense que je fais de mon mieux et que je
réussis à peu prêt à aligner les deux
d'où l'importance de l'année deux
suppléants tout à fait même race
important d'accord mais ce que france
pour la suppléance donc ils sont là et
découvre l'instance et à partir de après
la cinquième donc là en troisième ils
sont un peu plus à l'aise aussi ça à
s'exprimer doubs dont l'exemple de jade
d'accord prévient métis toi aussi tu es
conseillère départementale jeunes toi
qu'est ce qui t'a motivé
alors moi ce qui m'a poussé à faire
partie du conseil départemental des
jeunes
si le fait que cette instance nous
permet de nous exprimer de défendre nos
idées et de mener des projets qui nous
tiennent vraiment à coeur et le conseil
départemental est l'une des seules
instances qui permet qui permet aux
jeunes de s'exprimer de s'exprimer de
défendre des idées et surtout d'être
écouté justement en parlant de ses idées
toi quels sont les thèmes qui te fait un
peu plus vainqueur mois les thèmes qui
me tiennent le plus à coeur sont souvent
liées à l'aide d'allah
personne donc comme par exemple les
personnes en grande précarité comme
les sans abri donc on a eu la chance de
mener une action avec eux donc pas plus
tard que mercredi
une expérience formidable on a vraiment
retenu le lien social et c'était c'était
c'était vraiment génial ça restera dans
les annales de ma mémoire c'est un autre
thème qui me tient à coeur c'est aussi
l'aide aux enfants hospitalisés
donc mènera aussi une action
prochainement avec eux à leur est aussi
là c'est aussi la prévention pour pour
l'indépendance contre les drogues et les
addictions les addictions accord si le
tir et d'addiction voilà qui touche
reprend mais les eaux beaucoup beaucoup
de chaînes j'aimerais que vous me
parliez de votre relation avec les
jeunes du collège même dans lequel vous
êtes
comment vous les fait participer à cette
fonction de conseiller départemental
jeunes alors on leur fait part de toutes
nos actions de tous nos projets parce
que c'est aussi notre rôle en tant que
conseiller départemental jeunes de faire
le lien entre notre collège qu'on
représente tous nos idées et nos actions
vous leur demandez leur avis sur ce que
vous allez mettre en place
oui bon alors nous leur demande qu'est
ce qu'ils en pensent et aussi ont leur
ex pour l'heure explique un peu notre
fonctionnement nos actions donc il fait
un père f mais oui ils s'y intéressent
500 si on fait tout pour justement où
leur explique jacques toi tu as dû faire
campagne pour te fare elle est déjà en
tant que délégué dans mon collège mais
c'est vrai que quand c'est juste une
classe c'était ce n'est pas trop
compliqué après 1h collège la prochaine
étape c'était me faire élire en tant que
représentant du conseil départemental
des jeunes
donc en tant que suppléante en quatrième
et là on va dire je n'étais pas très
très expérimenté et bon j'étais je
n'étais pas vraiment à l'aise on va dire
prendre la parole en public
donc c'est vrai que c'est sans procès
us externe j'écris un discours j'ai fait
campagne en quelque sorte avec les
autres collégiens de mon collège mais ça
je trouve que pour ça m'a vraiment aidé
je veux dire pour ensuite passer l'étape
de être présidente du conseil
départemental dit je ne sais pas alors
vous menez des actions civiques et
citoyennes
qu'est-ce que ça recouvre exactement
donc c'est vrai qu'on mène pas mal
d'action donc civique et sociale et on
essaye à toucher le plus de personnes
possible donc comme me dit cela dit tout
à l'heure ça peut être avec les
personnes en situation précaire
ça peut être également avec les enfants
hospitalisés est quelque chose qui me
tient vraiment vraiment à coeur et que
j'ai dit durant mon discours
c'était le lien intergénérationnel donc
vraiment passer du temps avec les
personnes âgées passe pour moi c'est
très important parce que on est là les
réunionnais de demain la réunion de
demain et ils peuvent vraiment nous
apporter leur savoir leurs connaissances
et nous raconter la réunion d'avant et
je trouve ça vraiment très intéressant
alors on voit quand même pas mal dans
les médias quels sont les thèmes phares
que vous avez choisi de travailler cette
année
alors pour ce qui est ma commission donc
la commission nord on a choisi de
travailler sur plusieurs thèmes donc on
a mené une action avec que la spa
donc on avait pu passer j'en ai même les
animaux on a aussi mené une action donc
comme je l'avais dit précédemment avec
les personnes en conditions de précarité
on a mené une action avec l'usap et le
nss donc contre la malnutrition aussi
qui a eu lieu dernièrement journée
sportive et donc ça c'est pour ce qui
est de la commission dont on se réunit
on se réunit vraiment ensemble pour
parler de nos idées défendre nos idées
et surtout mener mener de véritables
projets de a à z sur de vrais
thématiques qui le tiennent à coeur
alors là on en a parlé de sécurité
routière récemment me forme louis
effectivement donc on a eu
une journée de sensibilisation à la
sécurité routière
c'était le mercredi 1er juin à
l'hémicycle c'était une pure accès à ces
grosses actions donc la plupart des
conseillers départementaux jeunes
étaient invités
on a travaillé avec la gendarmerie la
police la sous-préfète était présente
également
c'était vraiment une grosse action on
voulait vraiment de sensibiliser sur ce
sujet parce que cela touche de plus en
plus les jeunes malheureusement et c'est
la première cause de décès pour les
jeunes on a vu encore récemment et on a
ensuite voulu aller plus loin donc pour
faire passer notre message directement
sur le terrain la police avec la police
nous sommes allés faire un contrôle
routier
c'était y'a pas longtemps également le 9
à merveille et donc on a pu passer
directement notre message aux
automobilistes et à des jeunes comme
dans la continuité de la rencontre qui
s'est déroulée il ya quelques jours dans
l'hémicycle le conseil départemental des
jeunes s'est rendu sur le terrain pour
assister à un contrôle routier avec les
forces de l'ordre
aujourd'hui il s'agit d'une journée
prévention pour les usagers de la route
et éducation pour les jeunes ici présent
ça ces jeunes deviendront demain
paroles sont déjà usagers de la route à
travers des cyclomoteurs et aussi à
travers en étant passagers des véhicules
ne porte un message à leurs à leur vrai
nom la première cause de mortalité chez
les 15 24 ans à la réunion et l'alcool
puis la vitesse au volant
il est plus que jamais important de
sensibiliser les jeunes à cette
problématique pour le conseil
départemental des jeunes ce sujet reste
une priorité dans la continuité de notre
commencions play le mercredi
juin c'est bien intéressant de mettre en
pratique qui n'avait appris mais au
dollar s'est intéressée à sécurité
routière parce que tout simplement
seuls les conducteurs demain et c'est
vrai qu'on conduit pas encore comme
dirait beaucoup de personnes comme c'est
bien on souffre et les adultes
mais étant donné qu' il ya beaucoup
d'accidents c'est la première cause de
morts chez les jeunes est passé sur les
chaînes couleurs le plus sur la route
en plus quand c'est forcément nous qu'on
doit sensibiliser le plus en fait
là le contrat nous apprendre
e
et
les contrats commerciaux
tu es
quelque chose ensuite
c
comme si c'est
déjà assisté à
un maximum
plusieurs actions sur la sécurité
routière sont prévues pendant cette
mandature
il y aura d'autres activités
d'attractions tel qu'une affiche
l'arrière des bus et dans les collèges
toujours dans l'action d'obésité est
également un spot où les conseillers
départementaux jeunes pardon seront eux
mêmes le
un après-midi sur le terrain qui a
permis aux conseillers départementaux
jeunes de mieux comprendre le travail de
la police et l'importance d'une conduite
responsable
alors métis toi qu'est ce qui te plaît
le plus dans cette fonction de
conteneurs et parentales jeunes alors
moi ce qui me plaît le plus c'est que je
me sens écoutée et je peux mener des
projets de a à z ça donne un réel sens
de l'engagement et de l'investissement
mais aussi en faisant partie de cette
instance nous crée des liens avec des
personnes que ce soit entre nous donc
conseillers départementaux jeunes que ce
soit avec les personnes qui nous
encadrent sens qu'ici on ne peut pas
mener ce projet là encore une fois merci
de l'es6 et mais aussi avec les
personnes avec lesquelles on est on est
mené on mène des actions
oui beaucoup voilà les partenaires mais
aussi les personnes pour rencontre lors
de ces actions donc que les personnes
comme par exemple avec la fondation abbé
pierre
avec les personnes en grande précarité
c'est vraiment n'en ressort grandi c'est
une belle expérience vous mais pas été
un
alors rassurez moi les filles est ce
qu'il ya des garçons d'un congrès
départemental déjà la mairie
il ya beaucoup de garçons on va dire que
depuis quelques années une majorité d
mais il ya deux ans par exemple le
président c'était un un garçon va dire
que ça varie assez
non bien la parité ça vous parle
oui oui ça ne parle danse important
parce que on est aujourd'hui on a la
chance que que ce soit que conçois qu'on
peut être fille ou garçon
on peut s'exprimer dans la même égalité
en fait rétribuer way
voilà partager ses idées on sent très
bien jade est ce que tu penses que cette
expérience au sein du conseil
départemental des jeunes va te servir de
ton parcours futur j'en suis certaine
que ça va vraiment m'aider
déjà pour entre conseil départemental
des jeunes gt on va dire pas très sûr de
moi mais là ça m'a vraiment aidé à
prendre confiance en moi à avoir une
aisance pour parler en public à être sûr
de mes idées à pouvoir développer des
projets à prendre demande comment
comment on le fait et comme me disait
tout à l'heure mais this on en ressent
vraiment grandi on fait on fait des
connaissances et on apprend énormément
de choses sur la gestion de tout ce qui
a un peu de temps et cetera et en plus
on a la chance là de pouvoir vraiment
s'exprimer et d'être écoutés en retour
et vraiment il ya un échange et ça va
vraiment me servir et avant ça m'a aidé
à savoir également que je vais vraiment
aider l'autre et je pense aussi que ça
va vous servir beaucoup mais tu sais
c'est investir dans la vie citoyenne
défendre ses idées c'est une voix
laquelle tu aimerais poursuivre au vie
c'est vraiment pour moi le cdj a suscité
une vocation
donc j'aimerais m'orienter vers des
études de sciences politiques d'accord
et 20 c'est déjà une belle expérience je
devais d'en qui m'a permis de langage et
de l'investir et ça c'est important
très bien même robert un petit mot de
conclusion pour ces jeunes filles est
patente mois en entendant jade et métis
est vrai que je suis très satisfaite
parce que c'est vrai que bon ça fait un
bout de temps que
je travaille sur ce dispositif et je
suis fier de voir que les jeunes ils en
ressortent grandis et à un certain
moment quand ils sont troisièmes donc
ils peuvent s'exprimer plus facilement
bas la preuve jade qui le dit il ya une
certaine aisance
en plus ils apprennent à mettre en place
des actions dont moi je pense que c'est
un beau dispositif pour permettre aux
jeunes de vraiment d'être moins timide 2
et puis vraiment de de partir dans une
vie future vraiment réussir parce que
c'est vrai que je vois des exemples il
ya des jeunes qui qui était dans le
conseil départemental jeunes et viennent
des fois où on les rencontre eh ben ils
disent ils étaient en conseil général
des jeunes auparavant maraval et c'est
vrai que maintenant ils ont des
responsabilités et quand on les
sollicite
ils peuvent être aussi nos partenaires
donc quand on les sollicite il dit à moi
ça m'a fait plaisir d'être de vous aider
parce que ben j'étais conseillère
générale jeunes c'est vraiment très
encourageant et c'est un beau dispositif
qui doit être continuée est d'autant
plus que à la rentrée on va ouvrir au 5e
dont bernard 5e ont besoin de pouvoir
s'exprimer à partir de là il y aura
quand même une mandature de trois ans
donc vous mettez une nouveauté le
conseil départemental des jeunes eh bien
nous voilà arrivés au terme de notre
émission sur le conseil départemental
des jeunes nous remercions nos trois
invités
si et à très bientôt si on accepte la
télé
enfin
bon